uh our operations for onboard uh
international space station operations
we are in a weekend but the crew
on board uh is enjoying uh a day off
a day of cleaning and uh and some
exercise and of course they'll be
watching
today's launch from left to right we
have the expedition 64 crew nasa
astronaut kate rubins
and nasa astronaut victor glover japan
aerospace exploration agency suichi
naguchi
and then iss commander sergey rishikov
we also have nasa astronauts mike
hopkins and shannon walker
and rounding out at the very right side
isro's cosmos cosmonaut sergey kuzkov
again we just came to mission control
houston while polling a go for launch at
t minus 30 minutes
currently tracking no issues with the
antares rocket either
and mission uh contribution operations
center in dulles virginia
is also tracking everything is healthy
with the cygnus vehicle on top
uh now coming up on 30 minutes to launch
joining us for today's broadcast from
northrop grumman we'll be welcoming uh
christina halona
and terry systems engineering program
manager to walk us through some of the
features and milestones for today's
launch christina welcome
thank you gary i'm happy to be here and
welcome all of you watching here in the
united states and around the world to
see a successful and terry launch
and cygnus mission to the international
space station
wonderful we're getting a look at the
pad now looking at the n teres rocket
billing off some conditioned air tell us
about this rocket and teres 230 plus
yeah so gary the teres 230 plus vehicles
and upgrade to our previous antares 230
vehicle
which was under the previous year crs-1
contract
this ng-15 mission marks northrop
grumman's fourth cargo service
under the crs-2 contract with ng-12
being our very first antares 230 plus
mission which was flown in november of
the differences between the 230 and 230
plus are the upgrades to the stage one
core
which has lighter composite structures
and an optimized second stage motor
the upgraded stage one core allows
ontario's
engines to perform at full thrust
throughout most of the first stage
profile
the 230 plus vehicle also has a cargo
mass flexibility
in which the cygnus mask can be defined
within with the greater puncture streets
of course
but no later than 24 hours prior to
launch
so speaking of cargo another capability
of the antares 230 plus rocket is that
antares can
perform late load operations by the
unique pot top fairing and specialized
ground equipment
if you look closely at antares
you can see the nose of the rocket and
you'll see be able to
see the little pop-off that we that we
have there um
and that can be removed for the late
cargo load
um and anterior is having the ability to
do a late load
cargo load 24 hours before launch now
we're able to support critical research
experiments for nasa
and with all this talk about cargo the
interior vehicles carrying approximately
8 200 pounds of cargo to the space
station aboard the cygnus spacecraft
and we at northrop grumman are very
proud of our ontario's 230 plus rocket
and are dedicated to providing
the best value to our customers support
of our critical mission of their
critical
missions now christina we're getting
some
some uh footage from earlier when we
were uh
uh performing that late load capability
this is a good view of that pop top
fairing
uh from what i understand christina this
is this is near max capacity where we're
over 8 000 pounds inside uh
cygnus tell me about how antares is
ready to carry such a mass to the
international space station
yes gary uh you're correct this is near
max capacity
at 8 200 pounds for this mission um the
cygnus team has been
preparing the last few years of an
upgraded system to not only add more
cargo but also add more capability to
the spacecraft itself to support powered
payloads
cygnus has implemented additional
communications and telemetry
telemetry equipment to connect
scientists with
their experiments throughout the mission
from liftoff to arrival
at the international space station all
of these enhancement
enhancements point us toward a long-term
goal of growing stimulus capabilities
beyond
the space station resupply emissions we
also see
cygnus as a strong building block and
valuable commercial partner for the next
generation vehicle that will go to the
moon
and gary you mentioned before cygnus
we're so happy that
we're able to honor katherine johnson
for this mission and named her for ng15
you know as you mentioned before
catherine johnson
was an amazing nasa mathematician and
she broke many barriers
including race and gender while working
for nasa and delivered
critical calculations for a very
important mission that happened on this
day
and i also want to mention you know as a
native american and from the navajo
nation
catherine johnson was an inspiration for
me and countless others to pursue
degrees in aerospace
in the aerospace industry so i'm very
honored to be part of the human
exploration program and
i also hope to inspire others as
catherine johnson has to reach the stars
from setting their goals so
very happy to be here very good
christina hellona thank you for joining
us we'll come back to you here shortly
to walk us through some of these
upcoming milestones we have including
counting down to that
launch mark at 12 36 pm eastern and of
course walking us through ascent
we're going to go through some uh of the
great cargo on board
this is a nice uh graphic that shows
exactly what's on board cygnus we're
talking
over 8 000 pounds nearing 8 400 pounds
of cargo including pressurized and
unpressurized
you can see just more than 2 400 pounds
of that are scientific
investigations and there are quite a
number of them
first is the spaceborne computer 2. now
due to a need
to prioritize reliability over
performance computing capabilities in
space
are reduced compared to capabilities on
the ground this can create challenges
when transmitting data to and from space
although relying on ground-based
computers is possible for exploration
on the moon or to low earth orbit the
solution will be a little bit more
difficult for exploring farther into the
solar system so in 2017 the space born
computer study
ran a high performance commercial off
the shelf computer in space with the
goal of having the system operate
seamlessly seamlessly for a year
it successfully performed more than a
trillion calculations per second
for 207 days without uh
requiring a reset the space board
computer 2
will build on the success of this first
study exploring how
off-the-shelf computer systems can
advance exploration by processing data
significantly faster in space
with edge computing and artificial
intelligence
this experiment plans to demonstrate
that earth-based data processing of
current station science data can instead
be performed
on the station eliminating the need for
researchers to send
the raw data back to earth for analysis
could speed scientists time to insight
from months to minutes
we'll also have some space worms heading
to the international space station
tiny worms could help us determine the
cause of muscle weakening
that astronauts can experience in
microgravity astronauts work out for
more than two hours
a day aboard the station to prevent bone
and muscle loss
caused by living in a microgravity
environment during long duration
missions
thanks to a new device for measuring the
muscle strength of tiny c
elegans worms researchers with the micro
16 study can test whether decreased
expression of muscle proteins
is associated with this decreased
strengths and then
these results may support new therapies
to combat
the effects of age-related muscle loss
on earth
now of course some of these
investigations are scientific and some
of them
are technology demonstrations meant for
exploring farther into the solar system
there's an investigation called a haas
the international space
station serves as a testing ground for
technologies we plan to use on future
artemis missions to the moon
now the ahas investigation from nasa
puts to the test
uh some tools planned for use on the
crude artemis ii mission
that will orbit the moon built as a
primary radiation detection system for
the orion spacecraft
the hybrid electronic radiator assembler
assessor or hera
was modified for operation on the space
station uh verifying that hera can
operate without air for 30
days validates the system for crude
artemis art mission operations
a related investigation iss hera which
you're seeing now flew in 2019 aboard
the station
iss hera provided data and operational
feedback
in preparation for the orion
spacecraft's upcoming crude artemis one
mission
uncrewed artemis one mission
there's also another technology
technology demonstration to upgrade the
environmental control and life support
systems this is a system of regenerative
life support hardware
that provides clean air and water to the
space station the system will get an
upgrade thanks to the exploration
eclipse that's uh
environmental control and life support
system uh this is the brine
processor uh assembly the investigation
demonstrates
technology to recover additional water
from the urine processor assembly
using a membrane distillation process
now long duration crude exploration
missions require about 98
water recovery and there's currently no
state of the art technology and brine
processing that can help achieve this
goal
but this is one step closer the brine
processor assembly plans to close the
gap
for the urine waste system on the space
station
now these are all investigations going
to the space station we have another one
that's actually going to be deployed
shortly uh after the second stage
ignition
uh nasa in partnership with virginia
space is helping
launch 30 thinsets built by elementary
to
high school and university students that
will deploy from the second stage of
antares
once it reaches low earth orbit these
projects not only deliver scientific
data but also help shape a new
generation of scientists and engineers
thin stats will be released from the
second stage shortly after launch
and will transmit date transmit data for
approximately five days before
deorbiting and burning up upon re-entry
into earth's atmosphere
again currently tracking no issues to
launch antares and cygnus
looking good at the mid-atlantic
regional spaceport on pad
zero a you're looking at a live shot
from virginia
now i'm bored of on top of the
scientific investigations
are and the technology demonstration uh
hardware is some fresh food the
astronauts aboard the international
space station can be expecting
some cherry tomatoes some apples and
navel oranges
they'll also get some cold stowed cheese
parmesan and sharp wisconsin
cheddar
christina hellona we are coming up on 20
minutes to launch
counting down to the launch window
opening at
12 36 p.m eastern 12 36 and 49 seconds
that's at the opening of the window
tell us about some of the milestones
that antares has gone through up until
this point and will go through
to the t-zero mark uh sure gary so
approximately five hours ago of course
our amazing launch team
arrived in at wallops island in dallas
virginia and chandler arizona
in preparation for launch um the team at
the launch pad
will also go through their went through
their checks prior to evacuating the
site and then
shortly after we went through our
pre-power verifications right before we
power up the ontario's vehicle
once we power up and carries we run
various tests and checks to ensure all
is working well
on the vehicle prior to doing our
propellant loading
the team also gets various weather
updates and range updates to ensure
weather and range is clear
for launch as well at this point in time
seas about 10 17 a.m
we're just finishing off the tail end of
the propellant loading operations
once this is complete the team will top
off the propellant and we'll do some
field adjustments
then we'll do a final go no go pull it's
completed
and we'll proceed to the final countdown
to launch and then
at approximately three minutes prior to
launch you'll hear
that the auto sequence was initiated
this is where the antares internal
flight computers take over
and command the vehicle the auto
sequencer then goes through the final
steps they're prepping the vehicle for
launch and we'll proceed through the
final countdown and
launch off
and those milestones all coming up here
very shortly christina now take us
through ascent uh from the moment of
liftoff what can we expect to see
okay so antares will have a stage one
ignition not t-minus zero
and we'll lift off shortly after the
main engines will burn
for approximately 200 seconds and then
we'll go into mikko
and if you hear miko it means it stands
for main engine cutoff so once we get to
mikko we'll go into a short post right
before we separate stage one from stage
two
which we call the upper stack portion of
antares
will continue to coast a little bit
longer for about 30 seconds before
fairing separation
and then we'll have an internal
separation where the stage two flies out
of the external upper stack
once that stage two is clear of the
upper stack the stage two ignites for
two and a half minute burn that puts
thickness real close to the
to the orbit that they need to be in and
then we'll close to ensure everything is
stable
and then cygnus will be released into
the desired orbit
after stimulus is released we'll go
through some comp checks and then
about an hour and a half to about an
hour to an hour and a half later we'll
separate
um and cygnus will release its solar
arrays and be on its way to
international space station so
in summary takes approximately
approximately nine minutes to get cygnus
into orbit
that's right and we'll be providing
coverage throughout that time until we
have an
orbital insertion at that time we will
break
our coverage but we'll still be here in
mission control houston monitoring
uh the solar array deployment that takes
a few hours takes place a few hours
later
and confirm that over some of our
social media sites and our blog make
sure it is receiving enough power now
it's going to spend a cygnus we'll spend
about a day and a half
in orbit catching up with the
international space station
uh it's scheduled to be captured by the
robotic arm
of the international space station at 4
40 a.m eastern time
3 40 a.m central time on monday february
2nd
the robotic arm operators on board the
international space station will be
jackson astronaut
soichi naguchi nasa astronaut mike
hopkins will be backing him up
from inside the cupola for that coverage
we'll be uh starting at
2 a.m central time 3 a.m eastern
assuming an on-time launch today again
that capture time 3
40 a.m central 4 40 a.m eastern
once cygnus arrives on orbit it'll be
one of the several visiting vehicles to
be attached to the international space
station
after it is captured by soichi naguchi
robotic operators on the ground will
take control of robotic arm
and affix it to the unity module on the
nader side you can see there
sort of at the center of this
configuration of the international space
station
there are two crude vehicles aboard you
see on the left the crew one dragon
that carried the nasa spacex crew one
mission and the four astronauts aboard
to the international space station
and the soyuz ms-17 carrying kate rubins
and the two
uh russian cosmonauts to the
international space station
and of course the progress of vehicles
uh currently attached 77 which just
arrived
uh earlier this week uh on sunday and uh
on progress
75 uh attached to the aft end of the
international space station
fuel adjustment is not required copy 385
prop 2 configure occs for no adjustment
to fuel level
and in work
and lc prop 2 occs configured for no
adjustment to fuel level
copy that check 386.
and atom in 387 is not required
and launched amp advise 388 is not
required
this is mission control houston coming
up inside 15 minutes
counting down to 14 we're still tracking
our launch at the opening of the five
minute window 12 36 and 49 seconds pm
eastern time over in virginia 11 36
a.m central time here in houston
again everything is still looking good
uh as christina hellona
described they're topping off some of
the fuel in the antares rocket already
loaded
with that liquid fuel rp-1 kerosene and
liquid oxygen billowing off some of the
conditioned air
into the 32 degree fahrenheit weather
out there
at virginia still at about 75
favorability for launch today
lc this is cmd cygnus is in launch mode
and nominal
copy that cmd
and launch team llc countdown one at
this time on a poll to proceed with
final countdown
gso gso go
rso rsos go td
tvs go prop lead athletes go
stage one
lc stage one is go helium topping is
ongoing
copy that core one
uh in honor of alexander dictorov the
late director
director general of the eugenoi design
office whose efforts in international
space flight have contributed to the
success of antares
core one is go copy core one mes1
messes go gc gces go
and ace aces go mars
mars is go cmd cmd is go
ld ld is go ng
north of is proud to honor nasa
mathematician and space visionary
catherine johnson whose computational
brilliance and relentless pursuit of
excellence set the standard for 60 years
of nasa mission success catherine humbly
yet
forcefully broke the barriers of gender
and race to enable the future of
human space exploration and in the
process inspire generations
on this anniversary of john glenn's
historic friendship seventh flight which
would not have been possible without
catherine's calculations
bremen and the ss catherine johnson are
go
for launch copy ng launch team is going
to proceed with final countdown check
393.
coming up on 11 minutes to launch you
just heard that poll we are
go for launch again continuing to watch
that weather but uh
targeting still uh the opening of our
five minute window
at 12 36 and 49 seconds p.m is eastern
time
christina hellona if you're still with
us uh hearing some of the words coming
from
the mission operations center and all
the teams uh working so hard
on this mission tell me about some of
your thoughts as we're uh coming up on
inside
10 minutes to launch hi gary yeah so our
teams
uh spread out all across the united
states in wallops
dulles and chandler the entire team is
in these final moments are looking at
our
various telemetry data to make sure the
health and status of the vehicle are
within constraints
as you just heard there was a no go go
no go pull
of our antares chief engineer safety
officers and
leaders to continue the countdown and
we'll continue to monitor the telemetry
stream and make sure
antares is healthy and ready to go for
launch here in a few minutes
and we're coming up on that shortly
vehicle systems look healthy and we're
still
uh we're still 75 favorable and again
we're targeting the beginning of that
five
minute window so now that we've
conducted that final go no-go at the
t-minus
10-minute mark we'll be counting down to
about t-minus five
uh and teres will switch to internal
power at that time
and uh just a little more than three
minutes will be the auto sequence
handoff to terminal count the computers
will take over for the final steps to
get us to launch at the opening
of that window acs vdm's internal power
on
pdm's enabled voltage nominal odm
commands are clear
copy all like one check step 396 and
397.
and t minus eight minutes
mark by control gnc conditioning
initiated
copyright control check 399.
[Music]
inside seven and a half minutes are you
hearing some of those countdown
milestones
internal power has been activated it
will be switched here shortly
uh for the antares vehicle the
international space station is currently
flying 262 statute miles
over the middle of the atlantic ocean
just east off the coast of brazil
[Music]
nlc this is top lead vtso activation
verified
copy that lead check 400 ops 2401
initialized ground ordinance power
supplies
lc ops 2 ground ordnance power supplies
initialized
roger that select one cooker and grab an
ordinance power supply is nominal
copy like one check 402
t-minus six minutes
mark
now inside six minutes to launch again
again uh targeting the
ins the beginning of the five minute
launch window at 12 36
pm eastern time christina hellona as we
enter
uh these final minutes up until launch
any final words before we let you go and
follow the operations for launch
to be today and i appreciate the invite
and i'm looking forward to successful
launch go and terry
ops 2 lc step 404 you go to initiate
engine priming at t minus five minutes
lc op 2 engine priming started and ops 1
transfer avionics to internal power
avionics internal power on
external power off
now inside uh five minutes to launch uh
antares is now switched to
internal power christina hellona uh
thanks for us for joining us today uh
but of course she's gonna be busy over
these next uh
critical milestones here now that we're
inside five minutes and switch to
internal power the next major milestone
is coming up just a little over three
minutes
uh we'll begin the auto sequence handoff
to terminal count the computers will
take over
and antares will be counting down with
those computers automatically to launch
targeting again 12 36 and 49 seconds pm
eastern time
lc priming verified roger that uh
mes1 we'll check 412.
and we're now in terminal count
phase three dynamic limit will be active
at t-minus three minutes
three minutes and fifteen seconds until
launch terminal count targeting that
exact liftoff time
12 36 and 49 seconds tanks will be
pressurized at about t
minus 40 seconds and we'll be counting
down to t 0. everything's good
for launch today
auto sequence start audience voltages
and currencies
copy all that one gnc one step 418
verifier ready for nav mode
lc gnc one orb now ready for nav and ops
two you go to switch to nav
lc ops 2 switch to nav
open up telemetry verified copy all
check 419
and check 420 tlm you can switch link 41
to open loop
lctm copy
link 41 open
t-minus two minutes on my mark
mark
t minus 1 minute 30 seconds
t-minus one minute on my mark
mark
t-minus 30 seconds
t minus ten
five four three two
one we have engine
main ignition starter and we have
liftoff up and carry
for its ng-15 mission flight facility
engines are at one hundred percent
attitude
more pressures and equal substances are
nominal
the ss catherine johnson takes flight on
this the 59th anniversary of john
glenn's mercury flight carrying 8
000 pounds of cargo to the international
space station good performance on the
first stage so far
stage one continues nominal performance
inches at 100 percent
good core pressures
[Music]
engines remain steady added to nominal
max q attitude
[Music]
first stage passing through the area of
maximum dynamic pressure on the rocket
90 seconds into the light
[Music]
this first stage burns for a little over
three minutes three minutes 18 seconds
until main engine cut off
[Music]
about 90 seconds to stage one burnout
attitude nominal engines at 100
and steady
[Music]
t plus two minutes
all subsystems continue in nominal
performance
also some sub-systems are nominal
we'll be ready to shift down to uh 80 on
the engines
at 170.
startup slow throttle down
throttling down at three minutes into
the flight main engine cutoff coming
soon
throttle down to 55 percent
main engine cutoff we have miko
and terry's entering into a co stage
fairing separation will occur about 30
seconds later
as we lose side of the vehicle now
switching to animation
some control the firings on the inter
stage of the rocket
attitude nominal good separation
20 seconds to stage two ignition
all subsystems nominal
fairing separation
enter stage separation confirm fairing
separation and enter stage
stage 2 ignition stage 2 ignition
confirmed stage 2 is a solid rocket
motor burns for about 2 minutes 44
seconds
stage 2 will continue to burn for
another approximately
two minutes
altitude 138 kilometers
uh mission time 300 seconds
velocity 4.8 kilometers per second
altitude 150 kilometers all systems
continue to perform nominally
good calls five minutes 15 seconds into
today's flight
stage 2 motor pressure nominal
attitude nominal altitude is 170
kilometers
roughly one minute to stage two burnout
all stage two and gnc parameters
continue to be nominal
six minutes 15 seconds into the flight
uh coming up on stage two burnout of
that solid rocket motor that'll initiate
a
two minute coast period until uh second
stage separation
stage two starting to tail off
roughly 15 seconds to burn out
stage two burnout attitude nominal
stage two burnout good attitude uh we'll
er we're in a coast period now
cygnus exposed after that uh fairing
separation and will continue to carry
the second stage with it
until about nine minutes into the flight
attitude nominal
attitude nominal expected attitude
control system thruster firings
received continuing on course
roughly one minute to payload separation
altitude 185 kilometers
velocity 7.5 kilometers per second
all systems continue to operate as
expected
approximately 30 seconds to spacecraft
separation
attitude nominal systems continue to
perform as expected
attitude corrections uh maintaining
expectations
lc gso i just released red team to the
pad
copy that spacecraft separation
confirmed nine minutes into today's
flight cygnus has separated from the
second stage
lc ace that concludes our call outs that
ace
okay uh ng-15 excellent job today let's
go ahead and wrap up through this
post-launch checklist
and prop one uh can you report on status
of the pulse purging
pulse purging has just started copy that
we'll check 430.
and a gnc one lc when you have
the antarctic state factor to the cygnus
poc emailed confirmed
give me a call back on step 431
copy and work from the wallops range
control center in wallops island
virginia some celebratory
fist bumps as they successfully
delivered cygnus into orbit a
nine-minute flight
on top of antares from virginia space's
mid-atlantic regional spaceport
into orbit cygnus now flying free
the ss katherine johnson in flight will
make its uh one and a half day uh
journey
uh just a little shy of two days uh to
the international space station
arriving in the wee hours uh early
morning on monday february 22nd
harmony rotated arm enable indication no
longer illuminated
copy that option
and option disable your local launch
enable button
ops one launch enable removed engine
flight controllers in dulles uh
virginia northrop grumman's mission
operation center will take control of
the cygnus and uh monitor its approach
to the international space station over
the next couple of days
uh solar array deployment coming in a
couple of hours will uh
be breaking before that and we'll
provide a confirmation of that via our
blog
and social media before we depart with
you
today for our coverage of the launch of
northrop grumman's crs-15 mission to the
international space station we're
bringing on
uh deputy manager of the international
space station program kenny todd on with
us
to provide some remarks kenny thank you
for joining us today
hey gary good good morning good to be
with you
[Music]
kenny this launch comes ahead of a crew
rotation and of course
in the near term some evas from the
perspective of the international space
station program what is the significance
of this mission uh crs-15
well uh gary i mean this uh this
particular mission uh
um has um about eight thousand pounds of
of cargo coming to the space station
and uh you know roughly a third of it is
going to be dedicated uh directly to
utility
utilization and science on board on
board the station and so
again that's our that's our bread and
butter that's that's what we're up there
to do is
is really really do the utilization and
science that
that our commercial customers need the
things that we need to learn in order to
go further into our solar system our
human research and so
we've uh we've got a lot of this flight
that's dedicated uh
to to that kind of activity uh in
addition to that we've uh we've got a
little over a third of it that's
dedicated just to basic vehicle systems
maintenance hardware and some new
some new technology that we're bringing
on board so again
as we as we look to go further further
away
from low earth orbit the thing that we
have to do is continue to learn
you know about the systems that we're
going to need and and the iss provides a
great platform for that so we are
launching some
some new hardware in the vehicle systems
area that allow us to
to demonstrate some of this technology
and ensure that it'll be
be there for us when we need it in the
future
but then as always these cygnus flights
are very important to us because they
bring up a lot of crew supplies as well
they are a workhorse when it comes to to
to making sure that we keep our crews
sustained on orbit with
with the different consumables that they
need so again a very important flight
for us and we're glad to see it off the
ground and on the way to station
off the ground and on the way to station
on time kenny this is coming uh right on
the heels of
texas having some severe winter weather
now how were
international space station operations
uh continuously supported during those
rolling blackouts across the state
well you know there's kind of two facets
of that gary there's the
facilities you know the facilities
themselves are
from a power standpoint we're fairly
redundant we have generators here on
site in mcc
but you know we also have control
centers around the world gary that that
we can
leverage into whenever any any one of us
has a particular issue going on
um at their at their site and so uh when
you have a program
like the space station that's been
around 20 plus years um
i i i don't want to i don't want to say
we've seen it all but we most definitely
have had our challenges through the
years when it comes to supporting so
so one facet is the facilities and we're
in really good shape there the other
facet is just our people
and making sure that um you know we have
the
the the people available to come in and
and uh and work and make sure that we're
keeping an eye on
on our uh our friends and colleagues up
in low earth orbit and
and uh and having their back and and i
think the team has done a really nice
job here again because we've
we're very well practiced living here on
the gulf coast we're
pretty well practiced at a contingency
operations and
and knowing how to staff the facilities
and
and make sure at the same time that
we're taking care of our people and
their families
hey that's right and the crew is going
to be expecting uh all this eight
thousand pounds of cargo here in the
next couple of days tell us what's ahead
for uh when cygnus arrives uh in terms
of capture cargo operations
and some of the science on board sure um
you know we we talk a lot of times
around here in terms of dominoes and
and we have a lot of dominoes stacked up
right now when you look into
into february in the in the early early
part of march
um getting getting the vehicle to
station getting the cygnus there is
is that first domino and and with that
um we'll get the hatch open here
on the day that it arrives we've got
some some key science objectives that we
want to get going in that first couple
of days
um so so the first two or three days
after it gets there will
will be heavily and intensely focused on
on
the science that we need to get up and
running um
then shortly after that and merely you
know four or five days after that we'll
be heavy into
doing a set of eva preps uh we're at
this point planning on
on going out to do an eda in the in the
you know possibly as early as
next weekend uh we we've got a double
double eda planned um and so we'll we'll
get busy on that as quick as we get the
cygnus uh
let's get the science up and going that
came up in cygnus and then we'll we'll
be on
on to doing evas a lot coming up here in
the
near term kenny todd thank you so much
for uh joining us here at the
end of our launch coverage thanks for
having me gary i appreciate it
again we had a successful launch of
northrop grumman's crs 15
mission on time today 12 36 and 49
seconds p.m eastern time
you're getting a live look at the
mission operations center in dulles
virginia northrop grumman flight
controller is taking control
of the vehicle and will monitor its
approach to the international space
station
over the next near two days until it
arrives
in the early morning of february 22nd
monday morning
robotic operators suiji naguchi and mike
hopkins aboard the international space
station will be poised at the controls
of the canadarm2 the robotic arm of the
station ready to capture
it when it arrives monday morning
the uh cygnus is in orbit right now but
its solar arrays are not deployed we
will be wrapping up our coverage and
providing confirmation of that solar
array deployment here in the next couple
of hours
uh and that it is receiving power and
well on its way to make that journey to
the international space station
our coverage on monday morning will
begin at 2 a.m central time 3 a.m
eastern
to monitor the approach and capture of
cygnus in the eight
thousand pounds of cargo inside of the
vehicle and we'll also uh
be providing coverage of the
installation process robotic operators
on the ground will take control
of the robotic arm and maneuver into
position on the nader
side of the international space station
the unity module
where it will remain for the next
several months into may before it
departs
with trash and science on board to be
eventually
burned up in the atmosphere from
michigan control houston
and uh from all the teams that supported
the launch that will wrap up
our coverage of the crs 15 mission today
we'll be with you again on monday
morning until then
this is mission control houston
[Music]
you